que la révolution commence pour l'avenir
pour les gens
et pour la planète les
gens vont commencer à penser de toute façon les
gens vont commencer à penser qu'ils
ont à
quelle heure on rencontre ton mec
nous avons dit 11.
nous serons bientôt là content
de te voir frère  merci
tu penses qu'elle va bien ouais elle a
fait de la merde elle est bonne elle a fait ce
truc à eugene avec toi les tours cellulaires
ouais carrie taylor joseph maca
demain c'est qui nous ne sommes pas des exceptions
ami c'est à un niveau différent tu
sais qui
es-tu  va être capable de traverser
ça et de continuer est-
ce que tu veux dire est-ce que je vais appeler les flics
qu'est-ce que tu pensais qu'il allait se passer
quand nous nous séparons nous ne devrions pas parler
au téléphone ouais pas moyen qu'il n'ait pas de contenu
pas de contact non  contact
ouais il y a eu un peu
comme un accident les
gens vont commencer à penser de toute façon